yes it's friday
happy friday everyone what a great day
it's 175 days till new year's eve
god i love ryan seacrest
now it's not often i say this
but a politician did something i totally
absolutely love and no it doesn't
involve suicide you sick horrible people
but it does involve a democrat
i don't know what's wrong with me i mean
besides the obvious stuff but uh do i
have a head injury
oh if i had a dollar every time my mom
asked me that as a baby
after she'd pushed me off the bassinet
i mean but last night i complimented
hillary clinton
man did i get a ton of hate mail for
that
most of it from bill
but now i'm about to compliment
cory booker
no stop
stop i know it sounds like i'm losing my
mind but you remember corey i mean he's
the guy who says all this crazy stuff
this is about the closest i'll probably
ever have in my life to an i am
spartacus moment wow
that's like i am spartacus moment and my
testosterone sometimes makes me want to
uh feel like punching him and i hurt
when dick durbin called me i had tears
of rage when i heard about this
experience in that meeting and for you
not to feel that hurt your silence and
your amnesia is complicity
and i want to tell you when i look at
you this is why i get emotional
nobody's going to steal that joy
you have earned this spot you are worthy
he could so be a peloton instructor
it's true he can be a tad melodramatic
it's like he's auditioning for a
starring role in a high school version
of the music man
but he's not dumb
i mean compared to the squad the dudes
einstein
that's because unlike them his head is
only three-quarters of the way up his
butt
so he's getting some oxygen
but i like him for what he said on
monday
so here's a confession i have been
running now for almost seven months
straight
but my weight has been going up and down
because you can't outrun
a bag of oreos you can't outrun a late
night pint of vegan ice cream
and so i am challenging myself and i
want to challenge you too if you want to
join me on this experiment life is too
short not to try new things
from july 4th to labor day i'm giving up
sugar all added sugar in drinks and
foods you can't
outrun
vegan ice cream
oh man
i think we found our next thomas
jefferson
but finally a democrat who actually
addresses something real
not some
virtue signaling he's talking about
sugar which leads to obesity which leads
to death
or worse 80 year old women in bikinis
who would sneak that photo into my
monologue
sexist
cat
but finally
a democrat not spouting some woke crap
we're talking about sugar the bane of
our existence or should i say
the cane of our existence
i know huh that's why i'm seated here
and by hour i mean fleshy yo-yos like me
up and down up and down that's not just
my pecs when i flex but also my weight
and it's all cause of sugar i love sugar
so much that i eat sugar i feel the same
way about the bachelor but the bachelor
doesn't make my midsection grow like our
national debt
a little political humor there
very little
probably should have just edited it out
[Laughter]
so booker bringing it up makes him my
favorite democrat which i know is like
saying my favorite proctologist
who is gary
[Laughter]
i go once a month he has great
hands but booker's challenge is
practical and positive it's also free
maybe this is only what politicians
should do since they suck at everything
else they have no idea how to reduce
inflation or crime so why not try our
love handles and he's got a point
america uses tax dollars to make sugar
cheap then we end up with super-sized
people with super-sized health problems
and you know who i'm talking about
me but also we've all been to walmart
and seen a five-fat scooter pile up in
the candy aisle
or
two
i'm with them
i i've seen it yeah you've been in
costco costco
and there's two 400 pound plus people
beating the crap out of each other over
the last pack of family-sized twizzlers
their ass cracks exposed which is also a
great place to park that scooter
[Applause]
put it up go shopping
and think about covid who got really
sick it was the old but it was also the
obese and that's because obesity is a
co-morbidity for everything there are no
advantages except when it's cold outside
or possibly during a tug of war
have you walked around your town when
school gets out
no joke kids are huge and in a bad way
they're like giant inflatable versions
of kids
it's so bad the school bus drivers have
to make sure there are equal numbers of
kids sitting on either side of the aisle
or the bus could roll over while turning
it's so bad some kids now get to school
by rolling
this is not fat shaming tyrus this is
fat saving i am saying it to them and
i'm saying it to myself i put on over 15
pounds in the last two months and i
blame sugar i went from a solid 10 to
maybe a 9.3
thanks to famous amos that's my pot
dealer
but i digress
i work out every day that i cancel it
out by sucking down cookies because
they're sitting right there in front of
me on the dashboard of the treadmill
so i'm not criticizing you for being
overweight i'm really criticizing me
which i desperately need because being
the host of two hit tv shows and an
international sex symbol
i can't lose this girlish figure
so i not only credit booker for doing
something proactive i'm also going to
take the challenge so from now on to
labor day i'm going without added or
processed sugar now i'm not including
wine of course since it is a fruit
and i'm going to sweeten the pot pun
intended if i end up heavier on labor
day than i am now i will do one entire
show shirtless man boobs and all
i know it's disgusting
it's disgusting but if i end up lighter
than mr booker has to come on the show
dressed like spartacus
[Applause]
yeah how about that
corey
but his challenge gave this show an idea
why don't we come up with our own
challenge too
introducing the gutfeld challenge the
task no poop jokes until labor day
that's right no fecal humor of any kind
including jokes about dog food cat poop
horse poop pooping outside pooping in a
hotel or grandpa pooping with the door
open and that means absolutely zero
jokes about diarrhea constipation
farting sharding or those disgusting
public changing tables that are
definitely covered in crap for most
people this challenge is extremely
simple just go about your day not making
poop jokes but if your name is gregory
john gutfelt this will be the most
difficult two months of your life
true
gonna be tough so my advice for the rest
of you do not rely on willpower it's
about availability if something's around
you you're gonna eat it that's why i
don't have children
so get rid of all the stuff in your
house that's sugary that's half the
battle then the rest is keeping busy
idle hands always end up stuck in an
empty tube of pringles
true boredom leads to snacking and over
time snacking leads to this
so i'm going to join mr booker before i
turn into that
because we have to fight
obesity one step at a time unless of
course there's an escalator
tonight yes
she's taken more questions than biden's
taking naps co-hosts have outnumbered it
former white house press secretary
kaylee mcinerney
they say looks could be deceiving but
not this time
founder of
theloftusparty.com michael loptis
she's like a stately sea turtle
she could be well over 40 years old
tattoo
and finally
he never needed a booster seat my
massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyrus
so kaylee uh you are pregnant yeah
congratulations thank you
it's not that hard
it's like seven billion people on the
planet you know you're gonna applaud
everyone that's born that takes a lot
anyway
um so you get to eat for two yes yes it
is fantastic and you know first the
democrats came for my future babies baby
formula and now they're coming for a
pregnant person a birthing person's
sweets are you kidding me wait you're
against this idea yes greg i had a rice
krispie treat m m's and caramel
yesterday i'm already like planning my
dessert when i get home this is what
pregnant women do we can't have wine we
eat desserts well okay well what if you
weren't pregnant and then uh would you
would you take this challenge under no
circumstance you're telling me if you
pass like cupcakes from magnolia in the
green room you're just walking by i i
will i will you know what i usually do
i'll just spit on them
for everyone else ariana grande
spit on him that way no one can have him
if i can't have them no one will
it was just my high school like my high
school relationships
[Laughter]
why the hell are you looking at me i
don't know
i'm looking for help
you know it's so good to have katie lang
on the show
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
diary
greg really zinger
[Music]
oh man
can't fight back this is the name of the
show
so will you take uh michael i'm always
just kidding of course it's because you
wearing a jean jacket yes you look like
katie lange but anyway
in a super hot way yes exactly exactly
uh
would you take this challenge don't you
see there's some truth to this no
here's what i see i see a a crybaby the
drop out of a horrible acting class uh
getting ready to ban sugar that's what
he's doing this is all the groundwork i
came up with my own challenge i was like
spartacus like there's nothing more
annoying watching people uh who don't
have a weight problem talk about their
weight problem but that's what kaylee
just said she eats nothing but sugar and
she weighs like 12 pounds he once called
himself an overweight vegan by the way
cory booker yeah i mean this guy's got
like at the same time supposedly he was
with rosario dawson
right so she's smoking hot so i'm so fat
i can't even get a girlfriend hey shut
up i'm gonna be snorting lines of sugar
all night long like hunter biden
at a russian prostitute's house
[Applause]
i
i challenge you to give to give up sugar
and perhaps take up bathing
no
and no
although i just looked up what's a katie
lang and he's right you do look like
that
[Music]
whatever shall i do this is the most
time katy lang's name has been spoken in
20 years
cat
will you join me in this challenge and
salute cory booker like i think this is
and i i i i i
i have the same problem he says no
matter what you do when you exercise if
you eat sugar it's going to go it's just
going to negate everything yeah i'll do
it um but that's just cause like with
most commitments there's no way to
verify you're actually sticking to it
you can i mean you can say you're doing
it nobody's gonna know yeah that's true
which is but you pop you'll probably
just eat three steaks a day that's what
i'll do yeah that's exactly replace it
with you can eat
unlimited amounts of meat and lose
weight but i just i don't know it's in
anything that i eat because i don't cook
ever
like well not ever like a few years ago
i did
the pandemic was real bored i made soup
yes
all right okay
geez louise
you know it's really hard to come up
with monologues every day as you can
tell
i thought this would work
tyrus
you know what i'm talking about yeah i'm
with you i i agree like uh that's i
fought the weight monster he's always
hollering at me like you know whispering
like pizza in my ear or like
but
i want to i want to be with you with
corey but i have the brother drives me
crazy
[Laughter]
he always does things that i'm like
just spit out just say it he takes these
long walks just get to the point yes
there's no such thing as a bag of oreos
okay
no one's ever been caught by vegan ice
cream yes
it's baskin robbins and you're having 33
flavors you only have 31.
and he does things like oh we're gonna
make lynching outlawed for real
[Laughter]
you made it like it's murder in assault
i think we got it covered he does things
he puts he just needs to speed it up but
you're a thousand percent right and i
commend you for attacking because i
think it's corn fructose syrup i think
but it's the one addiction like when
everyone sees hunter biden smoke or
crack pipe like oh yeah but if they saw
me eating a cupcake they'd be like oh
he's hungry get him another one yeah you
know what i'm saying no one ever says
like hey
i fast after five o'clock i only have to
five anymore and i'm down like 35 pounds
but i have to change i had to change my
whole life to do it but you i would go
over somebody's house at six o'clock for
dinner and i'd be like actually i'm
sorry i i fasted i don't eat after five
and they'll be like
you can't have one yeah yeah just have
one it's just one day you've earned it
you're a big guy you have an appetite
and i'm like
i can't have one i'll have 47.
you know what i'm saying because it's
the one addiction we don't ever
talk about yeah obesity is it's just as
rough as cancer but it's because it's
become a happy thing you do at dinner
table you do you're surrounded by
holidays thank you so many options yeah
you just i think you should do something
with sugar at least
limit the size i thought it was great
when we got rid of like they had like
the 75 ounce big gulp yeah that's the
one i want you to do in america you can
do it all baby
but then you're mad when your taxes are
paying for everyone's type 2 diabetes
which by the way is really hurting
people who are born with diabetes
because all their insulin is in is
missing because it's going to type 2
diabetes there you go so but i know why
you think about that for a minute he
likes big gulp because he gets to use
the the cup afterwards to get the spare
change right
boom
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else